you said
um
the fact that uh the polls we read and
he said you know he's not running for
president he's never said he's running
for president he's running for 2022 but
he's also never said he wouldn't run for
president 2024 so it's kind of like
that's the first time tom brady like
i'll give you an example tom brady is uh
just lost to uh who they lose to they
lost to uh
uh the rams the rams they lost to matt
stafford came back and you know won the
game and we thought he was going to win
it but this is the first time i've heard
brady talk about uh retirement in a very
weird way you know he's not talking
retirement like flat out oh i'm coming
back next season have you noticed he's
not saying i'm gonna consult with my
family the first time he's ever been
waffling a little bit he's not
definitive so i feel like the reason why
there's all this chitter chatter about
uh ron de santa is because he's not
definitive his answer has not been i'm
telling you i'm not running his answer
is right now my focus is on being a
governor state of florida that's what
florida needs for us you know what would
you say to that
i mean i would say three years is an
eternity in politics like that's a long
ways away it's never really been asked
or expected of any politician to tell
you what they're going to be doing in
three years you know and he's being held
to uh by the media i think they're
they're intimidated by him in many ways
we're going to get to all this criticism
and stuff but i think he's he's almost
being held being elevated by them and
being held to that kind of standard that
most politicians are not held to so i
would just say yeah three years is a
long time in politics but he has not
said anything about running in 2024 um i
think it's wishful thinking among a lot
of conservatives because obviously you
know looking at what he's done in
florida a lot of people want that for
their states and that's great um but we
are focused on you know
getting him reelected here yeah yeah
there there is one guy i don't know he
lives somewhere in palm beach that i
don't think he has wishful thinking
about desantis running i don't know if
you know what i'm talking about he's uh
he's been around what's his name you you
know good friend of yours uh
president donald trump who lives at
mar-a-lago which it seems like there's
some uh back and forth going on right
now with conversations between the two
of them the media you know obviously
needs stories to build up we know that
at the same time you know but but but
also at the same time you know trump
just came up straight out and he said uh
there's some governors out there when
they're asked about boosters they're not
given the real answer even though they
took the booster they took vaccine they
don't want to give the answers i gave
the answer about the booster and it was
kind of you know insinuating maybe
that's governor desantis because the
interview with desantis when he was
asked about the booster it wasn't a
direct answer you don't see any friction
going on between trump and desantis
today no i think you know look at
trump's last appearance on hannity he
gave the exclusive interview to handy
hannity asked directly about this you
know hannity's on very good terms with
both trump and desantis who by the way
are on good terms with each other
president trump confirmed that he said
look you know we're good friends we've
supported each other
he's a great governor of florida and you
know basically all this narrative of
like friction and tension and all that
it's like great fodder for the media
because it gets clicks and that's really
what they're all about getting the
clicks and driving the traffic and what
better way to do that especially during
that particular week that all this came
out about two weeks ago now it started
that was when biden's agenda was like
crashing and burning it was when it
became clear that their
voting legislation is not going to pass
their buildback better is kind of dead
on arrival mansion and cinema you know
the two democratic senators that
defected so it was like all these big
priorities that fight it had oh the
supreme court ruled against the osha
vaccine mandate so these were like
failure after failure for the byte
administration on a huge scale so what
better way for the media that's
probiotics
i think it was a deflection from all of
these i mean i don't know about that and
the reason why i don't know about that i
have dinner with some very
you know people who have who have done
well for themselves and they follow
politics very closely and there is major
tension amongst people who want trump to
become the president again because you
know look let's face it nobody's
bragging about biden right now i mean
nobody when msnbc and cnn are sitting
there saying how this is terrible i mean
you know things are bad when they're
saying it's terrible what's worse than
terrible so no one's talking about biden
right now biden we'll cover a couple
things with biden
but i do see that you know the biggest
concern that comes up is
you look at the stage for debate and you
sit there and you say
okay i don't know if it's a good look if
trump and desentis is up there because
they're both extremely competitive so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you